>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[silence]
>> TOMOKO STEEN: Welcome, everyone.
I am Tomoko Steen at
Science, Technology,
and Business Division here
at the Library of Congress.
Today's event is organized
by our division, science,
and technology, and business.
Sometimes we co-sponsor these events
with other part of the library.
Today's speaker is
Dr. Ilya Zaslavsky,
is director of the Spatial
Information Systems Lab
at the San Diego Supercomputer
Center,
which is part of the University
of California, San Diego.
His research focus on
very complex program.
It's a distributed information
management systems and spatial
and temporal data integration.
So Dr. Zaslavsky received his PhD in
University of Washington in geology
in 1995 and before he came to this
country, he also received his PhD
from Russian Academy
of Science in 1990.
He has led design and
technical development
for several large cyber
infrastructure project supported
by National Science Foundation
and that's include Asque
and the National-Scale
Hydrologic Information System.
He's also co-chair of the OGC, WMO,
Hydrology Domain Working Group,
which is a way to develop
international standard
for the water data.
I hope I said the right.
Today, Dr. Zaslavsky is going to
talk about a very exciting topic.
SDG, which is Sustainable
Development Goals.
SDG is United Nations
initiative and its long name is
"Transforming Our World, the 2030
Agenda for Sustainable Development."
This is a set of 17 global
goals with 169 targets.
So the aims are: end poverty,
to protect the planet,
and ensure prosperity
for all of us on earth.
So the goal was put forward 2015 by
UN and before I go over difficult,
the words, I think it's best
to explain by the speaker.
So before further ado, please join
us, welcoming Dr. Ilya Zaslavsky.
[applause]
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY:
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Dr. Stein.
I am Ilya Zaslavsky.
I am gonna talk about
sustainable development goals
but sustainable development goals
is just one of the applications
of the software that we
developed and I will start
with describing general
trends in computing
and in cyber-infrastructure and
try to talk through transformations
that are happening in the computing
world and see how the tools
that we have been developing
recently help bring in more people,
engage users, and make it easier
to access data and analyze data.
So one of the applications is
sustainable development goal
indicators, but there are
several other applications
and time permitting, I will show
you if that would range from Picasso
and Van Gogh paintings to somebody
diversity image collections,
to other library collections.
This talk may be a little unusual
because I don't have
that many slides.
I will do the introduction and then
we'll try to switch to a live demo.
I'll tell you where I come from.
I work at San Diego Supercomputer
Center which is a fairly large
and one of the oldest super
computing centers in the country.
It was one of five original
centers founded in 1985.
We work on high-performance
computing and advanced networking.
But more recently, the focus
has been cyber-infrastructure.
I hope you've heard this word.
So these are the key part
here is infrastructure.
We're trying to make it
such that you don't need
to understand the details
of computing
in order to be able to use it.
Similar to electrical grid.
Electrical grid is a
very common metaphor used
to explain infrastructure.
You plug your appliance to an outlet
and you should be able to use it
without understanding the details
of how electricity is generated.
In computing, there of course are
lots of databases and cloud services
and web services and devices
and many different components
are involved in order
to deliver the data and
some services to users,
and users are not supposed to
understand the mechanics of it.
They should be able to just
plugin, to find the data or plug
in their own data,
and be able to use it.
That's, currently, a dream and a
very big challenge and research
on this area is being funded by
National Science Foundation and NASA
and DOA and other agencies.
Right. So, cyber-infrastructure.
And this slide is from Jim Crosier
who is the head of computing
and engineering department
division at NSF.
Just to give you an outline of
what cyber-infrastructure is
and what is the vision of
cyber-infrastructure at the NSF.
You have a lot of different
types of resources
that include cloud resources
and various compute systems,
storage systems and so on, and
some of these are supported by NSF
and there are of course lots of
resources in the commercial world,
there are international
resources, and so on.
On top of it, there
is middleware layer
where that manages
communications and exchange
between different systems and helps
to orchestrate the
systems working together.
There are some acronyms here
which I am not gonna spell out,
but if you have large
data sets sitting
in different storage systems,
you may want to connect them.
And so there is a brokering system.
If you want to access
these different systems,
you may need to have a single
sign-on system so that you don't log
in to each individual
system to work with it.
And on top of it, there are
science-focused applications
and there are a lot of tools
that have been developed
in this domain including various
APIs and portals and gateways
that support different sciences.
So, the dream is how to move
it to become more plug and play
so that we don't have to think
about each individual population
and the separation
are hidden from us.
Kind of towards the electric grid.
This is, as I said,
challenging because we see a lot
of transformation going on in
different areas of computing.
So that's another slide from NSF
which outlines so-called
cyber-infrastructure ecosystem.
And that includes organizations
and computer resources
and software and networking.
Changes are happening
in all of that.
Software used to be
developed by small groups,
now this is large-scale
collaborative activity
that involves multiple groups
working together so they have
to communicate, they have to be able
not to step on each other's toes,
so to make this work
smooth, organizations have
to align what they do to
support collaborative science.
Scientific instruments have to
plug in to the same infrastructure
and be able to not only provide
data but also provide information
about how this data
has been collected
so that you can always go back
and understand the origins and try
to explain where it comes from.
And of course, huge
changes in the data.
What we have been generating
in a year
or in two years exceeds
what has been generated
in all previous times.
And so the questions are, do
we want to store this data?
That's not possible,
because we generate more data
than we can store.
Do we want to somehow
mine this data?
How you decide what is important
to keep, what can be discarded?
And, most importantly, how to use it
such that it brings along
benefits for everybody.
So this is a very complex system
and transformations are going
on in all parts of it and
so, there's no surprise
that people are talking
about revolution
and sometimes call it
"big data revolution."
And these are just some of the
snapshots that I pulled off the web.
We're talking about forty zettabytes
of data in digital universe.
And zettabyte is 10
to the power of 21,
sextillion or something like that.
We have a huge amount of quantum
posted on YouTube and Facebook.
200 million emails sent each minute.
So this is a huge amount
of information to handle.
And if you want to make use of this
information, there should be tools
that can quickly parse this data.
And so, the entire
ecosystem, software ecosystem,
is changing to tune to
this amount of data.
How people have defined big data?
In 2001 there was an original
paper that started with 3 V's.
Big data is data that
has huge volume,
comes at you with high velocity,
and presents a large
variety of data types.
That idea of adding more
V's became quite popular
and that's a clear sign of
a marketing hype, of course,
so eventually you end
up with vendors claiming
that only our software can solve
your verisimilitude problems,
and other types of V's
that have been added.
But volume, velocity, and variety
are perhaps the most important
characteristics that
everybody who work
with data have been
trying to tune to.
>> So this is just to emphasize
the point that you really want
to have a grid-like
system where you don't want
to understand the crazy variety
of tools and systems that exist.
They have overlapping boundaries,
they don't necessarily
talk the same language,
connect with each other.
And it also highlights the
importance of nurturing new types
of scientists who can actually
navigate in this huge ecosystem
and figure out what is usable
and what is connectable.
That's the big data landscape that
is compiled from different versions
that happens every year and I'm
sure there are lots of systems
that aren't mentioned on this chart.
What we have been doing
in this space.
And so this is my lab.
We have been working, mostly,
on spatial data integration
and large information systems.
And I'll just mention
a couple of them.
One is Hydrologic Information
System.
I note here that this is the largest
in the world, probably the largest
in the world, it's hard
to make claims like that,
because it's not a single database.
It's a system where you can
connect to multiple databases
that follow the same language
and the same protocols.
So the first thing we did when we
tried to organize such a system is
to develop this common language.
It was called Water Markup language.
If you can expose your
data in this language,
then it will be unambiguously
interpreted by any client.
And that is an important component
of different systems
talking to each other.
So this language has been adopted
by multiple groups, universities,
and federal agencies, and as
a result, we have a system
where you can, from a single
client, you can query all of them.
Another interesting example is
with integration of brain data.
When you work with neuroscience
atlases, in this case we have worked
with atlases of rodent brain,
people develop photographic slices
and organize them as stacks.
And it is important to understand
distribution of the signal
that you see in one
collection of slices.
How it relates to something which
has been observed by other people
in other country and in a
different research group.
The key question here is how
you can relate information
about location in the brain.
It's not earth, so there's
no latitude, longitude here,
not to mention that all
brains are different.
So, you have to come up with some
kind of probabilistic specification
of location and then
develop services
that will exchange
information about locations
so that once you register
your slices to the system,
you would be able to get a
gene expression, segmentations,
and other data that somebody have
observed in that part of the brain.
So, you see from these two examples
that we've been working mostly
in the middleware realm, but I
was actually planning on talking
about a different project where
I think we are trying to tap
into totally different part
of big data challenges,
and that is making data
accessible and easy to use
by large groups of people.
So I will be talking about
the system called SuAVE.
SuAVE, no references to shampoo,
it stands for Survey Analysis
via Visual Exploration.
And surveys are treated
somewhat generically here.
So it's not just questionnaire
surveys.
It could be biodiversity surveys or
vegetation surveys, soil surveys,
and other types of collections where
you have information that may come
from observations from some
annotations from notes,
from devices, from anything.
And so you have various
heterogeneous of information
that you need to explore and figure
out where you start
subsequent analysis.
So, you see that there are
different types of applications,
even on this screen, I
have public opinion survey
and Van Gogh paintings, which each
of these paintings has some metadata
that you can use to slice
and dice your collection.
You can have different views
of the data, map views,
bar charts, cross tabs, and so on.
Before, I was hoping
to show you the demo,
I will talk about another
type of data revolution.
So, data revolution is a term
that is used by United Nations
to highlight the challenges
that people now have
with managing development worldwide.
It's very important to have
information about what's going
on in different countries
and how countries perform
on various matters, so that
to be able to make decisions,
and to be able to assess where
each country is with respect
to sustainable development goals.
So in 2014, there was a UN report
that proposed global
partnership for ...
>> Yes, thank you.
Partnership for sustainable
development data
and the key component
of it was agreeing
on sustainable development
goals and developing indicators
to monitor progress of every country
that subscribed to this document
and there're 194 countries that
agreed to follow that system.
So in September of 2015, this
program, "Transforming Our World,"
the 2030 Agenda for Sustainable
Development was adopted
that specified 17 sustainable
development goals.
This is the program for the United
Nations for the next 15 years.
In the previous 15 years,
the program was called
"Millennium Development
Goals" and that was adopted
after millennium summit in 2010,
also focused on 15-year period.
There were eight goals.
The progress has actually been quite
remarkable on these eight goals,
but very uneven across countries.
And these 17 goals have just
started so we have baseline data
for each country on these goals.
Goals include eradication
of poverty and hunger.
Establishing conditions for
good health and well-being.
Education and a bunch of other
matters, targets that deal
with development, especially
sustainable development,
ecological factors,
and social inclusion.
Let's try.
Right. So this is the website,
SuAVE.sdc.edu, and you can see
that there's a gallery, there
are news, there are blogs
and a few other common
elements of a website.
If you go to news and search for
SDG's, there will be an application
that deals with SDG indicators.
You see that what I have
here is a collection
of flags for each country.
You can look at different
types of representations.
Maps and so on.
I can map by, let's say,
Sustainable Development Goal rank.
So all countries are ranked in terms
of how close they are
to fulfilling the goals.
If I look at, let's say, Sustainable
Development Goal rank and look at,
let's say, the first 40, you
would see that the best countries,
in terms of closeness
to SDG indicators are
Scandinavian countries.
>> AUDIENCE: What is the source
of the data that each country ...
Do they create and generate their
own data, therefore it would seem
to be, probably, uneven and
inconsistent across 200 countries?
Where does this data come from?
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY:
Very good question.
So it is a fairly complicated
process.
There is UN statistical
commission, that compiles data
from multiple sources, and of course
it has to rely on local sources,
but there are multiple
verifications that happen.
The most difficult thing is to align
different measurement protocols.
But, one of the key goals here
was to define such indicators
that will be measured more or less
unambiguously among countries.
SDGI rank, something that I
showed, is just an average
of ranks on different goals.
Does that make sense?
>> AUDIENCE: Does SuAVE
normalize the data?
You said that the biggest
challenge is...
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: No.
SuAVE does not do it.
People who prepare the data do that.
We just take the data and make
it accessible and easy to use.
Okay. So, here you can...
So, these are 40 countries that
happen to be in good shape.
This is where they are on the map,
if you are interested in countries
that are at the end of the spectrum.
That's their locations.
And this is how they
are distributed by rank.
But in the same fashion you can
look at, you see that there are
about 90 indicators here,
not the 469 or so indicators
that have been proposed, many of
these indicators are very difficult,
actually, to compile
information for.
So even those indicators
that we have here do not have
complete coverage sometimes.
Okay? You can look at,
let's say, poverty below ...
percent of people who live on $1.90
per day - percent of those people.
So this has a fairly complete
coverage, but poverty rate,
these are only countries for which
poverty rate has been estimated.
So, it's not even.
It's, I should say,
a work in progress.
What I'm trying to demonstrate is
not where the data come from, also,
you can click on "About
Survey" and get the information
about the source and
follow that source.
But to show what the
software can do.
So, for example, sorry
about this, and...
You are looking at ...
One interesting characteristics
is subjective well-being.
Let's look at it.
That was estimated based on surveys
and it runs on a scale from 0 to 10,
so you can see how
countries are distributed.
It would be interesting to see
if subjective well-being
is actually how it relates
to objectively-measured
variables, right?
You can look at, let's say,
subjective well-being
versus, for example, poverty.
And you would see that it's
not, of course, a diagonal.
There are lots of outliers
on both sides.
There are countries where
populations subjectively think
that they're in good shape,
but poverty level may be high
and the other way around.
So if you look at these
countries, for example,
this is where poverty
level is fairly low
but subjective well-being
is also quite low.
These are Cambodia,
Gabon, Bulgaria, Sri Lanka,
so some of these countries
experienced unrest in recent years
or have been in the shadow
of some larger metropolis
and that may contribute to lower
values of subjective well-being.
So there may be multiple
explanations
that you can develop here.
I would probably just invite
you to play with the data,
because I will try to show
you that it's very easy
to play with the data and see.
Yeah?
>> AUDIENCE: I have played
around a little bit ...
I didn't find this one, but
I saw some of a similar one
and played around with it.
Is there a way in here
to look at the raw data?
>> AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Yes.
So the question is, is it
possible to look at the raw data?
So, again, if I go to about
data and click on this link,
it will open another webpage
where I got the data from.
And there you can get to the
actual spreadsheet and look
at the methodological description
and see, in the metadata statements,
where this data came from
and how they were computed.
>> AUDIENCE: And I was looking
at it, thinking about how to play
around with it with my own data,
so is that something you'll talk
about in your [crosstalk]
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Right now.
>> AUDIENCE: Yay!
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Okay.
And I also have my slides here.
Yeah, so, I'll do this in just ...
It will be the demo
after the next one.
So the idea is, as I said, totally
different from what I've been doing
in my regular research is how to
make your data accessible and how
to make it easy and fun
and engaging to work with.
How many of you have
answered surveys?
Any types of surveys.
At work, at ...
How many of you have ever tried to
access the results of these surveys
or have seen the results of these
surveys or tried to not just ...
Sometimes results come back
as documents, as pie charts,
and bar charts, but if
you would want to combine
and explore the variables,
you are out of luck.
And that is a very common problem.
So even if you go to
a government website,
such as National Cancer Institute,
or General Social Survey source
or another one, all you see here is
ability to load data in SPSS, SAS,
STATA, if you are a survey analyst,
you are in luck, if you are somebody
who is just interested in
exploring the data yourself,
it may be problematic.
So, this is an example of how you
can do surveys using the same data
that you can download from the site.
So, this is General Social Survey.
Probably some of you
have heard of that.
That is a survey that is
very important in the US.
It's been run by the National
Opinion Research Center since 1972.
Every 2 years on average,
there's an additional survey,
and people answer all sorts
of different questions
about different types of ...
I think I should actually
have it open somewhere.
No? No. Okay.
It opened.
Typically when you analyze
surveys, you work with tables,
you work with charts, right?
Here, the visual paradigm
is totally different.
Each respondent is an icon and
you just observe how these people,
these icons, form groups.
You can zoom in to
any person and see how
that person responded to questions.
You can have a few
additional visual dimensions.
So here, we know that
it's a white woman.
So you can specify your
icons to be representative
of certain variables you select
such as race, and gender,
or it could be other
variables, it's your choice.
Let's try to do some analysis here.
So one of the questions was about
happiness, general happiness.
Let's look at how people response
to about your level
of general happiness.
We see that 26% of people
say that they are very happy.
Let's try to explain that based on
some factors and we can try income,
we can try other things
that have been asked here,
or we can try a level of education.
Let's see, highest tier
of school completed.
Let's say 15 years and more.
That increases your level of
education somewhat from 26 ...
Your level of happiness,
sorry, from 26% to 31%.
You can compute the contribution
of this factor, so that's 5%.
In fact, this is somewhat similar
to a regression model but based
on mixed data where you
just compute contributions
of different factors
in the explanation.
In this case, explanation of
behavior saying very happy
in response to this question.
Interestingly, you can ...
There are several questions
about education.
If you look at highest tier of
education completed by spouse,
actually, your level of happiness
will be significantly higher.
So now we have 44% saying
they're very happy as compared
to previous 31, so this
contribution here is 18%.
And we can try to analyze it further
and see how it is different
by gender, or how ...
Actually, the first question
probably should be qualified by age
and marital status, because then
we can really compare these things.
But you can see that analysis
becomes quite simple here,
you just add additional factors.
So let's just say, that would be age
and gender, and there are all sorts
of factors here, so for one group
it will go in one direction,
for females it will go
in different direction
and I will let you interpret
the results yourself.
So, now, how you get your
own data into the system?
Let's say, I have a data
set that sits on my desktop
and it's just a CSV file that
is a survey of geoscientists
who were asked about
300 or so questions
about how they use different types
of data, how they use data developed
by others, what kind
of challenges they have
when they need to use
data and so on.
We can open this data set
in Excel and you will see
that this is a very standard Excel
file that just has questions,
has columns and these
are respondents.
There are 1500 or so people.
So it's fairly easily formatted.
Now, when you create an
account in SuAVE, you get ...
yeah, this is my account and I have
about 88 different
surveys in this account.
Once you create an account, you
will have a gallery like that,
but it will be empty initially.
So if you want to add a survey,
you just say, new survey,
point to this file which is
on the desktop that's
here, and give it a name.
Whatever you see survey.
That's it.
>> AUDIENCE: Who owns the data
once you've uploaded onto SuAVE?
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY:
Actually, you own the data,
and I'll show you in a second.
So this is your personal gallery.
For most people, I don't
know what they put there,
I just check the storage,
because you can specify this data
to be private and then it will not
show up in your gallery for others.
It will still show up for you to
manage this, but when others come
to your gallery, they
will not see it.
Right. So we created this survey.
You can already analyze it now.
But it's not really that much fun,
because remember we can also
associate a shape and color of icons
with some variables and that will
make it somewhat more interesting.
So initially it's just the
default, but everything
that you wanted to do is already ...
Population is already here.
So let's close that and make
it look more interesting,
so I will have a gender, I will
have male and female silhouettes.
So gender, it will parse the
file, and suggest icons for me.
Okay. I can also say that colors
will reflect primary discipline.
Let's say we have geoscientists and
computer scientists in that survey,
and those who said that they're
both geo- and computer scientists.
You can change colors,
and I'm gonna do that now.
And then you can also
specify what will show
up as a dynamic text
over each person.
So when you zoom in, you will
actually get more information
about that.
So let's do my primary role here.
When you submit it, it
should update the survey
and now you will have a somewhat
better way of looking at it
and also sharing it with others.
So it's much easier than trying to
figure out how you can find a tool
that will read SPSS
file or STATA file.
So here you can look
at distributions.
Let's say how people answered
questions about the importance
of different types of data.
And so, how important
atmospheric data for you.
So that's a distribution.
So you may hypothesize that if you
are atmospheric science person,
then atmospheric science data
will be important for you,
which will be generally correct.
Right. So I'm just
subsetting this for people
who declare themselves atmospheric
scientists, except for one person,
who says that the data in his
domain are of low importance.
I think we can actually click
on this guy and see who that is.
I mean, not who that is, but how
that person answered questions
and tried to explain
why it happened.
So this is a way to zoom in from
overall picture to deviant cases
and kind of make this
observation of,
transition from your general
view to view of a single,
small group, very smooth and easy.
And then if you are interested in
this pattern, let's say you want
to share it with your coworkers,
you have a distributed group,
then you would say,
"comment on this,
look at this interesting
behavior on the left."
Right? So you can save
this annotation
and then you can share this
annotation with others.
So you just click share and
that will generate a link
that you can put on your Facebook
or send to your coworkers or put
in an email and then when
users click on that link,
they will open this same view
and can take exploration
in other directions.
So, that answers your
question somewhat.
>> AUDIENCE: Yes.
Thank you very much.
Would you mind also [inaudible].
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Yes.
So. Right.
In this survey, I don't
have location information.
If I would have latitude and
longitude as two columns,
then I would just click the map
here and it will show me a map.
If I don't have latitude and
longitude but I have address,
I will specify that this
is address information
and I do believe it will geocode
on the fly and create a map,
so there are two ways to do that.
>> AUDIENCE: To me, It looks
like it's a very powerful
system for describing data.
Is there also a component
that would account for some
of the statistical power, the
statistical properties of surveys
or different types
of survey designs?
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Right.
So the question is can this
system be made more traditionally
statistically powerful?
And the answer is, somewhat ...
Well, of course, it's a yes,
but it's actually a
little bit more complex.
We are trying to develop, to
make it such that visualizations
and statistical measures go hand
in hand and reinforce each other.
When we compute traditional
statistics, quite often,
they would not have that clear
visual expressions compared
to increments or decrements
of conditional frequencies.
So those changes in conditional
frequencies, which generally is
on the fly on the client side, as I
showed in the table of rules before,
where you can compute contributions
of selected factors to explanation.
We also have a connection with "r".
So. I'll show you in a second ...
If I would ...
Oh, yes. So, here, I can also
say that I want to include "r"
and it will include an icon on the
right that will allow me to call
"r" via our open CPU interface
and pass variables that I defined
as independent variables
and dependent variables
to "r" to compute.
In this case, we have
enabled logic, pro fit
and log-linear models
but can be done.
Yeah. The same bridge can be used
for other types of computations.
Does that answer?
>> AUDIENCE: Do you think you
can verify a little after, again?
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Right.
So we have applications in different
areas and since I promised you
at least Picasso, I'll
have time for Picasso
and then we might have to wrap-up.
You may go to the web page
and you would find, actually,
a bunch of galleries of artists.
So I have Picasso, Van
Gogh, Dali, Balthus, Bosch,
Rivera, and a few others.
So, let's look at Picasso.
And this really demonstrates
the power
of doing exploration
with visual images.
So these are paintings.
And as you see, as you zoom in,
you get higher resolution versions.
You have heard, I'm sure, of
different periods in his life,
like blue period, pink period,
African period, and others.
Let's try to detect these periods.
So, I would turn on
paintings that have been done
at the turn of the century.
And sort this by year.
And here you go.
Right? Indeed, towards the end of
1901, he fell into a deep depression
that lasted three years,
or almost four years,
and typically it's attributed to
his friend and fellow Spanish artist
who lived in Paris and was a
good friend, Carlos Casagemas,
he committed suicide, and so,
Picasso went through
some very dark times.
And most of the paintings
are also ...
The subjects are beggars
and all sorts of ...
>> AUDIENCE: How did you get the
data to describe the paintings?
Is it input metadata, or
is it a visual software
that visually analyzes the colors?
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY:
Very good question.
Both ways.
I work with several art historians.
They sent me data.
So, for example, the Van Gogh data
set, it came from Lev Manovich
who works in New York,
and he's director
of Software Studies Initiative
and also practicing artist.
So he studies so-called
style-spaces.
You can place photograph of a
painting in multidimensional space,
look at clusters, and see
how as artists moved from.
Let's say one place to another,
whether it corresponded
to change in clusters.
>> AUDIENCE: Based on what?
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Yes, based
on brightness, hue, saturation,
plus other things that
you get from the picture.
Other things become more difficult.
Brightness, hue, saturation
is fairly easy to get
and this is what we
have in Van Gogh.
So maybe I can show you.
So, there are two ways.
There are actually
more than two ways.
One is to pre-compute some
of these measures based
on image characteristics.
Another is let people come to
this application and annotate it
in the way I showed you
and they would be able
to capture some more information.
And then, we also have a system
where people have been
annotated based on forms,
so that the information goes
directly, goes back into SuAVE
and people can analyze
it immediately.
Does that answer your question?
Right. So, in the future,
we are planning
to have a somewhat more advanced
system where people will be able
to define, themselves, what
kind of additional attributes
of pictures they would want to
extract and bring into an analysis.
For now, it's done outside
the visual interface.
>> AUDIENCE: Did you have
some animal locomotion there?
When I first came into the
room, that was on the screen.
There were horses running and I
wondered if you had worms crawling
and turtles going and what all.
And I thought I saw
our animals there.
But you don't.
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY:
I don't have horses.
I have tigers.
>> AUDIENCE: Oh.
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: So, it's been
used for camera trap images.
And you can look at a
collection of images and,
let's say, tigers or onkas or ...
And see at what ...
It all depends on what
metadata you have.
You can see at what times
of day they are active
or at what temperatures
they tend to show up
and it's actually interesting to
compare it across different species.
I also have examples from
a system called iNaturalist
where people contribute their
photographs of what they observe
in their yards and that goes into a
large image archive with metadata.
So I have some examples with that.
Not with horses, no.
Yes, and I have one last
slide, I think that will...
Yeah, so the types of applications
I more or less described,
I will skip that and the last slide
is, this is really an invitation
to explore what you can
do with the data yourself.
It's a free system, it's
open-source system, it's supported
by National Science Foundation,
and you can create a login
on the system, you will
get your personal gallery,
upload your data, and play with it.
We opened it up about 5
months ago, we have 90 users
who load their data, and
you're very welcome to do this.
I really think that making data
easily accessible will make a
dramatic impact on the
this-called data revolution,
or make a real difference there
because it will increase the level
of trust that people have in
any statements based on data
and it will let people play
with the data themselves,
which is interesting.
Thank you very much and
sorry about the difficulties.
[applause]
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Questions?
>> AUDIENCE: I have
another questions.
Could this handle a
genuine big data set,
like computational
fluid dynamics data set?
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY:
We'll need to talk.
So, the question is, "can this
handle very large data sets?"
We have interfaced it with a system
that has about 400,000 records.
So, of course, you cannot put
400,000 dots on a single screen.
The maximum we had so far was 8300.
And these were images
of macrofossil samples
from British Geological Survey.
It's a fairly large
application about 30 GB worth
of data, well I should ...
I can say in one screen.
But really, at some point these
are dots and when you zoom in,
you actually get more information.
So, with large collections, you
have to first search and come
up with some subset that
will be meaningful to display
in SuAVE and we've done that.
So, if you have some specific
application in mind, we can talk.
>> AUDIENCE: [inaudible]
>> ILYA ZASLAVSKY: Thank you.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.